Tyler Morrell is a pizza delivery man
for Coco's Pizza and Aston in
Pennsylvania he was making delivery
recently when he noticed a high-speed
chase unfolding right behind him that's
when he stepped in to help officers make
an arrest watch
a high speed chase
[Music]
holy smokes Tyler Morrell our Employee
of the Month joins us tonight Tower
thanks so much for coming on as a former
pizza delivery guy myself I never was
called upon to do anything like that I
don't think I ever could responded as
quickly as you did how did you were you
a former soccer player like what was
going through your head how did you do
that so fast
no so I was a uh I was a former lacrosse
goalie which I am attributing that quick
thinking to my quick reflexes in the
cage so
I'm so impressed when I'm sorry I
skipped ahead what was going on behind
you do you have any idea
um so right when I got to the door I
could hear uh the the sound of sirens
and then right after that you hear the
loud Screech you hear the car hit the
curb almost flip over into a house
um and at that moment I knew I was in
the middle of something
did you ever find out what exactly it
was
well they were uh they stole that car
oh
so it was uh they stole the car uh there
was a couple other charges that were
listed there as well now what was so
striking and so cool and the reason we
were so happy to make you employee of
the month is that you see these videos
all the time in a crime will occur and
there'll be some guy doing his job
delivering pizza and 99 of the time the
guy says to himself you can almost see
it I'm not getting involved like this
got nothing to do with me but you did
not say that why
um it just felt natural to me
um I just was raised to do the right
thing and that felt like the right thing
I didn't want anything to happen I I
didn't want any sort of incident to
happen I didn't want you know just with
the things that go on in this country I
just didn't want anybody to be hurt in
this situation I think I may have been
the most hurt in this situation but I
was happy to take the injury for US Open
out the Brookhaven Police Department
what was your injury
um so I have a very bad uh bone bruise
on my leg because of that I did not
intend to catch him in the middle of my
leg I got him I tried to catch his foot
just uh make him trip a little bit and
uh so the Brookhaven Police Department
could uh to could Wrangle him up
I just I gotta ask so this guy you don't
know exactly what's going on but you
know something serious has happened a
felony and this guy's running right
towards you and when you have to decide
whether to trip around did you ever
think like what if I don't trip him and
he comes and shoots me were you worried
at all yeah so my biggest concern I saw
him reaching
um you could see him reaching when he
was passing that one car and I didn't it
looked like he was trying to throw drugs
out of his pocket uh but so the pocket
didn't seem big enough to have a gun so
I kind of knew even at that point I
would have just tackled him I mean I
would have gone for it
you're the best last obvious question
did you deliver the pies in the end
yeah pies were delivered unscathed and
eaten on video
ridiculous man if I lived I'd order
three of them tonight
sausage and pineapple I would love to
deliver them to you
bless you for coming on for what you did
tell him morale thank you
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else